I know but I gotta talk about this
amazing award you received the very
prestigious and well-deserved award you
presented with it's right here on our
table the Walter Cronkite award for
excellence in journalism from Arizona
State University at a ceremony in
Phoenix yesterday Kirby and will yeah
they're right there with you uh the dean
of the Cronkite School said this is the
quote her approach to covering important
events and interviewing politicians
leaders and celebrities is unparalleled
Gail told the audience how her dad made
the family watch the CBS Evening News
every night and that is what started her
love of Journalism watch this
Walter Cronkite came into our living
room from reporting the news and people
trusted that he was giving them the
truth my dad was one of those people he
passed away when I was a freshman in
college but I really can't help thinking
of him today because he would be so
proud of this moment a that I even work
at CBS let's start with that
and then B that I'm standing here
getting the Walter Cronkite award for
excellence in journalism
I mean the water Cronkite award now
Oprah Winfrey could not make it to the
ceremony but she did send a very
heartfelt video message
I do not know of anybody who deserves
this award more than you because I do
not know of another human being on the
planet Earth who is more Curious more
compassionate more caring of other
people's stories
I I wish we had time to play the whole
videotape because all of you guys were
on the tape Oprah was on the tape and
then there were just people from my life
who I'd worked with in the past I didn't
know what was going to be on
it was such an amazing surprise to sit
there and then have favorite daughter
Kirby who hasn't been on a plane in
three years yes right to get on a plane
and travel through an airport in over
three years but she came and I even said
you guys don't have to come you know she
goes of course I wouldn't miss it well
was there it was just very very and not
just will but and some CBS cheeks yes
like that's a big deal George was there
when the man was there Ingrid Supreme
Matthews was there
Shawna was there Kristen Sam were there
Gisele and radar I know Giselle and Ray
Don you know they had to be there they
always
makeup artists in case people are
wondering yes it was amazing but you
know I grew up thinking that the news
was boring and my dad said no we have to
watch it because you have to know what's
going on in the world needless to say I
no longer think it's boring because I
grew up in Turkey where we didn't have
television everybody read books that's
why I still read a lot of books today so
we had to watch the news every single
night and it was Walter Cronkite yeah
and now so here I sit here at this table
that's the way it is that's the way it
is